κι εδώ μισονεόνα ζωής θαν έχι και παραπά οι κύπρος είναι από τις χώρες τις
ευρωπαηγής εμεσεςμε τον πίο ψηλο να αριθμο φραγμά των κατακεφαλί πρέπει α σας πω ότι
άλλες χωρις τώρα δουλεύουν το κομμάτι της αποθίκευσης νερούς τα φράγματα εμείς είμαστε αρκετά προχωρημένι
στο κομμάτιν αυτόν σίγουρα τα φράγματα μας χρειάζονται ενέργειες για να διασφαλίσουμε ότι θα δουλεύουν
σόο τααγματα περίπό έχουμε παραου εκατόνακάκααα περίκαι έναν υπάλελο νατα εξεπας ως δεν έχουμε έναν
υπάλει ολον είχε ότανδά ναι ένα επιθεωρήτής τσι όχι επιθεωρητής συγνώμη υπεύθυνος επι τής ασφάλειας
τ δυπηρεσίας φάλιες φραγμάτων την ανάλειψη των καθηκών δομα ακριβώς επειδή εκανα κι εγώ ότιν
ίδια ερότηση αυξήθηκε σταπένται αυτό είναι πάρα πολύ έτσι σημαντικν αλλά δε μας ικανωποί αυτός
ο αριθμός για ατόν και δουλεύουμε να αυξήσουμε γι να δημιουργήσουμε το συνεργείον που χρειάζεται
για να κάμνουμε τις τις ενέργειες που πρέπει το ενδιάμεσον εννοείται ότι δουλεύουν οι ηλειτουργεί
του ταή και προσπαθούν ναν τα πεξέλθουν με το προσωπικών που υπάρχει έμεναν αυτό δεν
με ικανοποιί είναι κάτι που δουλεύουμε μαζί με το τμήμα και με τη διοίκήσυντουπουργείου για
να αυξήσουμε να ακόμα περισσοτερό τς θέσεις μας σε επιστημονικών και τεχνικών προσωπικών και έχει
πει και αυτόν ίδη κιο προχωράστον κόσμο που άνηξυχή για το καλοκαίρι σε δε αφράτο
κεφάλιο να απο κοπές καλοκαίρι θα αρθικε ο τουρισμός και τα ξενοχία τι απτας ταξι
απαντούμε αυτό το οποίον πραγματικά συμφαίνει ότι ι συνεχίζουμε να δουλεύουμε έτσιωστε να συνεχίσουμε να
παρέχουμε το εκατόν της εκατόν της ίτρευσης πότε θα υπάρξει ξεκάθαρικό να θα υπάρξουν απόκόπλεςαυτό
θα εξαρτηθεί από την περίοδον της της εχμίς του τουτουρισμού όσον πουλησιάζουμε προς το καλοκαίρι
ενδεχομένο τον πρώτο θες να το περάσουμε μέσα στοπάσχα